oh holy thigh ball who needs God when I
have your loving embrace yeah oh you
know just studying some religion okay
then
home alone by myself for a while what to
do what to do you hmm well I am by
myself I guess there is one thing I can
do I guess I could you know beat that
meat alright well that was a pretty good
session should probably get to work now
too though
okay let's see what we got
hmm new message from book Walker hi Giga
we have a new app in development where
you can talk and interact with mega men
from Connor super would this be
something you might be interested in
maybe so it looks like the apps called
the ISA kai app hmm I want to refresh us
a brand thing off they're actually gonna
add more esky characters in the future
well might as well give it a download
and see what happened
but this is it we've done it boys we can
finally start talking to our wifey's we
are one step closer to achieving the
dream all right let's just enter the
name oh wow
she'll actually call you by the word you
put down weight so she'll call me
anything
is there anything I've ever wanted a
waifu to call me do i do it now i can't
do its come on even I'm not that much of
a degenerate I haven't fallen that far
yet I hate myself
oh man it's my own actual pocket waifu i
wonder if i can hear patter did I just
get rejected from a head Pat did anime
lie to me alright let's see what else we
got
alarm stopwatch timer one what happens
when it reaches zero alright well I
guess I should try actually talking to
her
let's see hello how are you step on me
you know this is actually pretty cool so
this is why it's like to talk to an
anime girl but now that we have the
sound and greetings out the way time for
the real question is it true that our
waifu's will actually love us do you
like me oh my god this is it I've lived
my entire life for this moment the 2d
girl just said she likes me it's
happened it's really happened what am I
supposed to do now I should say
something yes I should definitely say
something all right
you know what I'm ready everything I've
done has prepared me for this moment
I love Emilia you know now that
technology has taken us to the point
where we can actually interact with 2d
girls I guess there's something I should
probably make sure of how old are you
can I see your ID well I mean if she
says she's old enough to drink alcohol
and get married I would drink to that ha
ha take that FBI you know I'd never
thought I'd be sharing a drink with some
2d girl but here we are wait a minute
she never actually told me her age I
wonder what it actually is how old are
you really
ah [ __ ] ah [ __ ] and the FBI arrests you
if you are in Japan oh hey she has a
pajama set as well but would I really
pay money just so I could see megamen
input job I didn't even know why I even
attempted to question that good evening
wait did she just no it can't be I'm
sure it's just something getting lost in
translation because there's no way she
means what I think she means yes good
night
[ __ ] are you sure the FBI can't arrest
you in Japan maybe this is it maybe this
is my future my destiny am I still even
in the real world did I finally get Issa
guy to a world where waifu's exists and
actually love us I guess that's it
goodbye worthless Tensai goodbye holy
Fievel
this time I have the real thing and I'll
actually treat her right
I just wish she was a little taller than
my phone wait a minute yeah that'll do
[Music]
Hey
ah [ __ ] hey guys hope you enjoyed that
video
thank you very much the book Walker for
sponsoring this video and of course
giving me the chance to play around with
this app I honestly think it's a really
cool idea for an app I mean what we've
hasn't dreamed of talking to that why
Foose is still in the early stages
though so I'm really looking forward to
how far they take with this and what
characters they may add in the future
the English patch just got released so
you can click the link in the
description to download it for yourself
today and give it a try and you can also
give megohm in a tree because they just
released her new birthday outfits
because today is megamans birthday so
yeah
happy birthday Mega Man I'm celebrating
a fictional characters birthday where
did I go wrong in life